hey crazies I want to start by letting
you know that I am not quitting YouTube
I know there's been a whole string of
those videos the best of which from Tom
Scott godspeed Tom that being said I do
need to make a few changes for this to
be
sustainable this first one is the big
one I want the channel to be viewer
supported up until recently science
Asylum Revenue was mostly made up of
three equal slices sponsors which are
branded segments that I read and embed
into a video YouTube ads that run before
after or sometimes in the middle of a
video and patreon a platform that helps
creators get financial support directly
from viewers sponsors are a huge source
of stress for me not because of any
specific Brands I've worked with I've
always been pretty choosy about that the
number of sponsors I have turned away
for moral or ethical reasons it's it's a
lot but I think we can all agree that
sponsored segments kind of pollute the
viewing experience it makes me miserable
every time and I hate it so I'm going to
try not to take any sponsors in 2024 but
that means a huge chunk of my Revenue
just disappears to make up for the loss
I've started freelancing again but
getting your help would be better if you
have it to spare and feel like my work
deserves it please consider supporting
the science Asylum through patreon for
as little as $1 a month you get access
to a live Q&A we do at the end of every
month it's a pretty good time and we'd
all love some new faces in the chat
you'll also get access to the science
Asylum Discord server where deeper
discussions can happen sustainability is
key though so please do not overextend
yourself trying to support us if you'd
prefer YouTube memberships are a great
alternative to patreon you'll still get
access to the monthly live stream an
icon next to your name in the comments
and some custom emojis if a one-time
purchase is more your speed I have an
advanced physics book for sale speaking
of which the price is going up at the
end of January so if you were on the
about buying it now is your chance to
get it at the lower price links to all
these options are in the doobly-do and
if financial support just isn't in the
cards for you right now I completely
understand your continued viewership is
greatly
appreciated for years I've been failing
to convince the normies to care about
the topics I'm into and I'm not
interested in covering most of the stuff
that they're into let's face it I'm
weird so I'm done looking at analytics
they shouldn't matter I'm going to embra
rce who I am and make the videos I want
to make regardless of whether or not
they'll perform well my video on
planetary Rings is a good example of
this I need to convince myself that
below average performance does not equal
bad I loved making this video and I
thought it turned out really good anyway
it's become clear to me that I have no
idea what makes a banger and when they
do happen they're unpredictable
something I learned the hard way back in
2022 I'm just so tired of worrying about
whether or not my video videos have a
broad reach you're the people I want to
make videos for anyway so again if you
can please support my
work no more mid Roll YouTube ads the
ads that run before and after the video
are fine those are going to stay for now
I'm just dropping the ones that run in
the middle of the video I've always felt
sick about it and YouTube keeps making
them more awkward and intrusive over
time I'm done they're going back off are
these changes I'm making terrible
business decisions yes I'm I'm a
terrible businessman if I was a good one
I would have capitalized on the viral
videos I had two years ago and hired a
team to crank out content every single
week the quality length and schedule
would be Machine level consistent I'd
basically be went over Productions
nothing against against Sam that that's
just not my journey I don't want this to
be a business I I don't want to be a
manager I'm an educator I want to
educate all I want to do is teach you
stuff that I think is interesting and be
able to pay my bills that's it I have
have no bigger Ambitions so again again
please consider supporting my work in
2024 and to those of you who already
financially support me thank you so much
you're the reason I haven't quit yet
physics has always been a hard cell on
YouTube and I'm kind of an acquired
taste let's be weird together and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little
crazy
[Music]